We've talked a lot about different
monetization strategies in your game,
but one more thing to consider is
how to make money outside your game.
So how can you generate
alternate streams of revenue?
>> Well,
you can create physical products.
Things like t-shirts or toys that
have your game characters on them.
>> I've even seen games that sell
their own merchandise in their stores.
I've seen t-shirts like you
mentioned and even phone cases.
>> Mm-hm, yeah.
Games can promote their own merchandise
by putting it in a game store or
even displaying their own ads.
>> Merchandise can get be a great way
to monetize if you have a big fan base.
>> Companies like Amazon offer an easy
way to create and sell merchandise.
For example,
Merch by Amazon is an on-demand
service that let's you sell t-shirts
with your apps logo on it.
>> Yeah, so as you're building
your game, keep in mind
that you aren't limited to end game
purchases and ads to make money.
There are many other
innovative options out there.